[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
nearly two years after his death a
sentence is handed down for the murder
of ahmad aubry i think in this case the
record speaks for itself
and the defendant's own words i think
guide this court with regard to
sentencing and accused oxford high
school school shooter ethan crumbly
appears in court wise defense team
waived a preliminary hearing plus the
latest in the sexual misconduct case
against former new york governor andrew
coleman and later jurors get the first
glimpse of defendant chandler
halderson's police interview we know
your parents are no longer with us
okay and we know the reason why
okay you need to tell the truth law and
crime daily covering court cases from
coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to long crime daily i'm
brian bachmeyer along with terry austin
a judge hands down his sentence for
three men who shot and killed an unarmed
black man as he was running through a
georgia neighborhood last year
greg mcmichael and travis and michael
and william roddy bryan will spend the
rest of their lives behind bars for the
death of a mod arvery in november of
father and son gregory and travis
mcmichael and william roddy bryan were
convicted of killing aubry travis
michael shot and killed 25 year old
aubry in february 2020 as he was jogging
near his brunswick georgia home meg
michael and his father tailed aubry in a
pickup truck and brian followed in a
separate truck he captured the shooting
on video that footage which was leaked
online and sparked national attention
showed travis firing close range shots
into aubry defense attorneys claim they
were attempting a citizen's arrest a law
that has since been repealed and
replaced travis michael was found guilty
of malice murder and eight felony
charges his father and brian were found
guilty of felony murder assault and
false imprisonment among other charges
georgia law states the three men would
receive life sentences on friday
prosecutors asked for life without
parole plus 25 years for greg life
without parole plus 35 years for travis
and life with the possibility of parole
for brian several motions from brian's
attorney were denied by the judge
there are
hundreds in georgia and probably
thousands of individuals around the
country who are serving life sentences
have been in prison for many many years
who drove the
the car that was used to escape from the
armed robbery uh or provided the key to
to break into the house not knowing that
it was occupied it doesn't matter
whether you're white black or martian
it's still wrong
for the legislator to legislature to
require this court to compel this court
as a matter of law to impose a mandatory
life sentence on an individual who
hasn't killed attempted to kill or
intended to kill
aubry's family gave witness statements
after the sentencing his parents asked
for justice to be served for their son
we love our son and we
would never have him with us to
celebrate anything
thanksgiving christmas
for his birthday
his kids should spend the rest of their
lives
thinking about what they did
and what it took from us
and this should do
it from behind bars
because me and my family we got to live
with his death the rest of our life
we'll never see a mart again
these men
deserve the maximum sentence
for their crimes
ahmad never said a word to them
he never threatened them
he just wanted to be left alone
they were fully they were fully
committed to their crimes
let them be full let them be fully
committed
for the consequences
judge timothy wamsey handed down the
sentence to the mcmichaels and brian
late friday afternoon
as to travis mcmichael
mr mcmichael the court sentences you as
follows
count one
malice murder
life without the possibility of parole
that is life plus 20.
greg mcmichael the court sentences you
as follows
count one
malice murder defendant was found not
guilty
count two
felony murder
life without the possibility of parole
that is life plus 20 years
roddy brian i do want to separate
a little bit because the state is making
a different recommendation
court sentences mr bryan to
life with the possibility of parole on
count three which gives mr bryan a life
with the possibility of parole sentence
the three men will also face a federal
hate crimes trial next month joining us
today is legal analyst dina dahl and
terry austin dina what did you make of
goff's emotions where the other
defendants joined filed just hours
before the sentencing why so late and
did the judge handle them well
essentially what the moshe was trying to
do was say that the law this sentencing
was too much and but this is not exactly
something that the trial court would
have been able to determine this is
something in appellate court state
supreme court u.s supreme court would be
able to only say that the law is
unconstitutional
his motion though was preserving this
issue for appeal his client though
actually did get parole so the issues
moot he won't be using that for appeal
the judge decided to give him parole
because he felt like he showed remorse
after the fact he cooperated with the
police as we know the video that was
taken by him was released he felt that
he something should be done about this
in the judge's opinion made sense there
terry were the sentences of the three
men a just one and what stuck out in
your mind during the sentencing
i definitely thought that the sentences
were just the first thing that stuck out
to me was that the judge took a moment
of silence for one minute he said that
it was because ahmad aubry was running
for five minutes and the terror that
must have been in his mind when he was
being confronted and so i thought that
was very poignant and he also said to
determine those sentences he listened to
the words and the actions of the
defendants themselves he said for greg
he established this narrative trapped
like a rat he said for travis it was the
worst day of his life well think about
the day that ahmad arbory had he said
for brian y'all did you get him and that
too indicates that he was intentionally
trying to get this individual but like
in um dina said
he did show remorse so the judge did
become more lenient as far as he was
concerned yeah those life sentences at
least in georgia is about 30 years in
jail for the mcmichaels you've got 20
years after that it appears that brian
may have the ability to go to the parole
board after 30 years but he's what 52
years old so he'd be a quite old man by
that time when he has that opportunity
thank you both
this week on prime crime a one-time cold
case gets solved decades after the 18
year old high school student is brutally
murdered law and crime's jesse weber
joins us now to explain how
investigators crack the case wide open
jesse
hey there brian yeah on our next episode
it's all about the cold case killing of
michelle martinko back in 1979 now this
is a murder that went unsolved there
were no answers for years but then you
fast forward to 2018
and there is a breakthrough there's one
suspect jerry lynn burns when
investigators ultimately interview him
at his office all captured on body cam
footage if you haven't seen it it is
fascinating to watch
this is a level of violence
in a very public place
that very few people even to this day
uh would see
um and involving
um
a young lady that was beloved beloved in
her community really engaged with her
school
um
and a member of the the school choir uh
was a a major red i think and these
sorts of things had tons of friends and
just really beloved and
she just doesn't come home one night
so
i think that you know by virtue of how
well this case was documented back all
those years ago back in 79
we were able
as a result of moving forward in the
future the investigators and then us in
the media we were able to breathe life
uh back into michelle and we go through
the whole case from the crime scene in
1979
all the way to the conclusion in 2020
tune in to lawn crime
thanks jesse you can catch this week's
episode of prime crime friday night at 5
30 p.m and 10 30 pm eastern time
still ahead on law and crime daily
former new york governor andrew cuomo is
back in court the latest developments in
his sexual misconduct case but first the
accused oxford high school shooter
appears in michigan court why defense
attorneys wave the right to a
preliminary hearing
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live one
crime network with youtube tv for all of
your daily live trial coverage legal
news expert analysis and original true
crime programs subscribe to youtube tv
today and then locate law and crime in
the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily the
boy allegedly responsible for a michigan
school shooting last year and his
parents who are charged in relation to
the crime all face a judge on friday in
separate hearings in december the
defense attorneys for james and jennifer
crumbly the parents of the alleged
oxford high school shooter ethan crumbly
requested to have their bond be lowered
that request was denied friday when a
judge decided to keep the couple on a
500 thousand dollar bail each a
preliminary hearing for the crumbly
parents is now scheduled for february 8.
the couple are charged with four counts
of involuntary manslaughter after ethan
allegedly shot and killed four of his
classmates ethan who faces 24 counts
including murder and terrorism charges
also appeared in court friday for a
probable cause hearing it was later
rescheduled after both the prosecution
and the defense requested more time to
review evidence ethan waived his right
to a preliminary hearing judge nancy t
karnick bound the 15 year old over to
circuit court
circuit court will soon set a trial date
for ethan he was denied bond at his
arraignment after the shooting when he
entered a not guilty plea during the
hearing friday the judge said bond is
expected to be addressed again in the
coming weeks
let's bring in legal analyst dino doll
and terry austin to break down the
latest in the oxford shooting terry is
there an advantage to waiving a
preliminary hearing why do you think the
ethan crumbly's defense decided to do
this
well look the whole purpose of a
preliminary hearing is for the
prosecutor to demonstrate there's enough
to go forward and it's like a mini trial
the prosecutor will bring on witnesses
the defense has an opportunity to
cross-examine those witnesses but the
defense can waive that right and i think
in this case they waived the right
because they knew there was enough to
proceed and maybe they didn't want to
tip their hand as to what their possible
defense just might be
dina did you expect a different result
from the crumbly parents hearing and do
you think the judge made the right
decision to deny a change in bond
i'm not surprised there are two factors
the judge would consider to reducing
to bond are they a danger to society and
are they a flight risk the first one
they're probably not a danger to society
but they're definitely a flight risk i
mean they had to they left the city they
withdrew cash and left the city and were
found in this warehouse i mean they
demonstrated that they were willing to
leave and so i'm not surprised that
their bond wasn't reduced yeah of course
the you can ask for bond to be reduced
at any point in time maybe future
arguments will come up as the judge
suggested and as they do we'll be here
at law and crime daily to give you the
update coming up on law and crime daily
a wisconsin man accused of murdering and
dismembering his parents we show you the
moments leading up to his arrest plus
will andrew cuomo have his day in court
while ruling a new york judge made about
the state's former governor
[Music]
welcome back a new york judge dismisses
a forcible touching charge against
former governor andrew cuomo
cuomo faced a misdemeanor charge in
albany county he was accused of groping
former aide brittany camiso in 2020. the
sheriff of albany county charged cuomo
but the district attorney david torres
said he wasn't notified soros issued a
statement earlier this week
saying quote kamiso was credible but the
state couldn't meet its burden at trial
this was the only case which for which
cuomo was charged with fondling a woman
those allegations and a report on them
from the state's attorney general led
him to resign last summer in a statement
cuomo said in part quote for the last
several weeks we have remained silent
while the process played itself out do
not confuse our respect for the justice
system with acquiescence
you to break down the former governor
andrew cuomo's court appearance is legal
analyst dina doll and terry austin terry
did you think the judge actually had the
power to stop this case from being
dismissed or was it done once the
prosecution filed its motion
well any judge has the power to dismiss
the case suspente or on their own but i
think it's very rare for them to do that
without emotion here the prosecution
basically was asserting that this was a
misdemeanor charge that they couldn't
prove it and so it should be dismissed i
think this whole case is very unusual
from the very beginning the sheriff
brought the charges without conferring
to the d.a so i'm thinking that the d.a
might have done this because he wants to
send a message to the sheriff don't
bring a case without talking to me first
so dina kamiso the complainant in this
case is credible but they couldn't prove
the charges why do you think the
prosecution dismissed this case why not
leave it to a potential jury to decide
according to the prosecutor there was
exculpatory evidence
that the sheriff wasn't aware of and
that this made it less likely for him to
be able to get a conviction and that's
the most important thing here
prosecutors don't want to bring a case
unless they think they can get a
conviction even though sometimes there
is evidence if it has to rise the level
of beyond a reasonable doubt it's a very
high standard so if indeed there was
anything exculpatory that they did have
it makes sense that they decided hey
it's up to us to bring this not the
sheriff it never they may never have
brought it to begin with in this respect
it looks like maybe something's fishy
happening but if they had never brought
up we never would be having this
conversation absolutely and and to add
to that point too prosecutors unlike
defense attorneys or other lawyers have
a very unique ethical duty to only
prosecute cases in which they think they
can win on they can't just bring
frivolous claims so to speak so thank
you for that both when we come back
emotional testimony from the defendant's
ex-girlfriend we head to wisconsin and
chandler-halterson stands trial for the
murder of his parents
welcome back to law and crime daily as
the first week of wisconsin vs chandler
haldison winds down the jury hears a
police interrogation with a defendant
for the first time
prosecutors say 23 year old chandler
hall in a senate murdered his parents 50
year old bart and 53 year old krista
halderson in july 2021 after that they
say halterson cut up their bodies and
attempted to burn their remains in the
family fireplace he laid or scattered
other body parts of theirs across
southern wisconsin on thursday
hardison's former girlfriend catherine
cat mildred meldrum
took the stand she told jurors holderson
asked her to bring ice hydrogen peroxide
and a swiffer wetjet to his family home
things got emotional on the stand when
she told prosecutors about her interview
with police
did you believe that
you or chandler had done anything wrong
at that point no
okay
were you emotional during emotional
during that interview
yes
how do you express your emotions
sometimes
i cry a lot or
if i get too anxious um
or emotional i start vomiting
those things were happening that night
yeah
police asked at times to look at your
your phone and and photographs and
things of that sort
pardon
and did you show them anything they
wanted to see
anything they wanted yeah i gave to them
why was it important to you to
cooperate at that time
because i like
i just believed his parents were missing
and i just want them to be found
the next day jurors were shown
hollowson's police interrogation
going to start with a clean white piece
of paper for you to start telling the
truth okay what because listen listen to
me this is the only chance you're going
to have
to tell us the truth okay okay what we
listen listen
i can't tell you what we know but we
know you're not telling us the truth
we know your parents are no longer with
us
okay and we know the reason why
okay you need to tell the truth there's
listen listen you need to tell the truth
about what happened and just tell us why
it happened
okay
if something happened if you were
defending yourself or if you just got
fed up with stuff
you need to tell us the truth okay
this is your chance to tell us why you
know what happened we're not going to
tell you what happened you know what
happened you were there when it happened
we're not bs okay
you know more
than you think we know i actually
but
there's people that have told us things
we have we have evidence with proof that
more has happened okay
so your parents never made it to the
cabin and i think you know that
[Music]
dina the prosecution weaved in simple
facts like the girlfriend bringing ice
or hydrogen peroxide to the halters at
home where do you think the prosecution
is leading us in this trial of death and
dismemberment
it's astonishing how many facts there
are in this case i mean the defendant
here talked quite a bit he has a web of
lives that came out
he manufactured a text from his mom you
know from his own phone and the
girlfriend as we saw there had no idea
that this was happening you know he
buried the torso of his father on his
girlfriend's property and they were able
to tell that from the data on the cell
phone that they obtained from her
and then later they end up even finding
the gun on the girlfriend's property as
well so there's quite a bit of facts
here um very gruesome um coming out in
this case
yeah i know in law school they tell
taught us about arguments that a single
stick can be broken but a bundle of
sticks uh is almost impossible to break
and as i see this case being built it's
like stick by stick by stick by stick
being put together for quite an
unbreakable case terry we got our first
glimpse of halterson's police
interrogation on friday he answered
questions without an attorney but
clammed up when detectives prodded him
for the truth how do you think this
evidence will play out in front of the
jury
i don't think the evidence is going to
play out very well at all brian the jury
is looking for signs as to whether or
not this defendant is lying and they
want to see whether or not he cooperated
at the time and this looks like he's
being very evasive it looks like he's
hiding something the police are trying
to get information out of him but he is
not cooperating and i think that when
you look at that interview you can
determine that he's lying and he's made
other lies in the past so
the fact that you can see this interview
is really good because i doubt very
seriously whether or not he's actually
going to take the stand and it's great
for the jury to get an opportunity to
actually see him speaking so they can
determine for themselves he's a liar you
know the body language the tone
everything's going to be judged and
they're going to come to a conclusion
well thank you both and thank you for
joining us here on law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you